sentencing for Mike Flynn being pushed
back until March after a dramatic day in
court the federal judge saying he was
disgusted with president Trump's former
national security adviser for lying to
the FBI and warned that he could be sent
to prison the judge also sparking a
media firestorm after questioning
whether Flynn committed treason before
walking back his comments the White
House is reacting today and is standing
by it's criticism of the case and also
blasting James Comey what we do know
that was inappropriate by own self
admittance of James Comey is that the
FBI broke standard protocol in the way
that they came in an ambush general
Flynn and in the way that they
questioned him and in the way that they
encouraged him not to have White House
counsel's office present and we know
that because James Comey told us that
and he said that the very reason that
they did it was because the only reason
that they did it it was the Trump
administration and they thought they
could get away with it all right Dana
the judge making a lot of headlines
today judge Emmett Sullivan has a very
good reputation but you know he said the
treason thing and then he walked it back
and then he said well you were working
for a foreign government while you were
working in the White House talking about
Turkey and then he got the dates wrong
had to correct that what did you think
about today's events well I think it's
good to remember that judges have this
discretion and this power and it's one
of the reasons it's so important like
who you put on the bench right so
president Trump's focus from day one as
president has been to try to get as many
judges confirmed as possible and the
Senate has been able to fulfill that and
so Emmett Sullivan is known as somebody
who he gets a lot of cases through his
court he is not shy about getting press
attention but earlier this week well I
guess was Monday he went from hero to
zero in a week right because he had
asked I want to know more about this
situation if you say you came here and
you pled guilty but you're saying now
that the FBI agents like tricked you so
I need to know more about that and I
want everybody to deliver their
documents to me so for a week we spent
having people think oh the judge is
gonna throw the whole case out mm-hmm
because of this thing the first thing he
asked him today is do you want to change
your plea no does the FBI do something
bad you know
okay so fines I think in a way
in the court of public opinion that
works a little bit flames lawyers at an
excellent job of getting him to where he
is where he was going to get no jail
time but again with the judge they have
discretion so sentencing guidelines are
only that they're guidelines and the
judge is basically indicating that he
was possibly going to get jail time
today
Flynn's team asked for a recess they go
back and they're gonna delay it now for
three months yeah if you're looking at
no jail time I wouldn't flirt with
anything they could that could lock me
up even for a day I would not do well in
prison Gregg everybody knows that and
long as you don't flirt only only you
would do worse tonight oh thank you very
much this was like today was like when
you're on the tarmac of a delayed flight
and the guy comes on it says now we're
going back to the gate we'll go back to
the gate a couple of thoughts the judge
seemed very disgusted with Flynn but I
think it's because Flynn didn't give the
judge what they what he wanted right it
was something but they didn't get
everything they needed it was like the
judge wanted a Playstation for Christmas
but he got it you know a jumping rope
that's how I got from that but I'm gonna
go back to the feta to the question that
I asked that people hate is this news
it's a news hangover right this is the
lingering headache and nausea from 2016
that won't go away so the media here and
elsewhere it feels really dramatic it's
really important but it's not it's not
this is just the only game in town right
now because it's the holidays and
because under Trump the country is
rolling along pretty well try to ignore
the stock market because it's the end of
the year that tends to happen but things
are going along we have declines in
crime terror optimism is high so the
media needs to focus on this thing the
Comey the Flynn the collusion it's like
a triangle of idiocy right by the way I
do believe he will get if anything
happens he will get pardoned and I think
it's I think he deserves a pardon if you
compare to previous pardons like this is
nothing compared to the people that
Clinton pardoned Clinton pardoned like
how many people in the last day Margaret
well 16 terrorists 16 FAL and terrorists
he pardoned people who tried to bomb our
country or did bomb our country so if
you say think that Flynn doesn't deserve
a pardon read your history yeah I mean
here's our wicked
veteran yeah I think I know what you
were talking about when you said the
judge was looking for something because
they had been sending up smoke signals
Jedediah that you know maybe he was
gonna pull his plea maybe he was gonna
come out and tell the judge I was set up
you know I didn't really lie and the
judge was kind of asking are you really
gonna go that far and the minute the the
Muellers team heard that that was a
possibility they just dangled that
turkey consulting thing that he was
unregistered as a foreign agent and
they're gonna hit him hard if he if he
doesn't do it they agreed to do this
whole story becomes so confusing because
you can't reconcile it on so many levels
I can't reconcile why he lied as someone
who was a you know incoming national
security person you would expect him to
have some contact with Russian
ambassadors why would he lie then you
look at why you would be advised not to
have lawyers present if that's not Shady
it certainly looks shady then you look
at the fact that the agents knew
essentially what he had said to the
Russian ambassador they already had the
transcript so what are you going there
and interviewing him for you already
know are you looking to entrap him then
you have the 302 which is the FBI
document about the report and it's filed
nine months later after the incident so
so many things about the reason I think
it's gonna ultimately either get you
know there's gonna be a pardon or
there's just so much nonsense you have
one of the people interviewing him winds
up being Peter struck which is the guy
who has you know those of those text
messages there's anti-trump text
messages to his lover the whole thing is
a disaster I don't know how it's gonna
end but you can certainly look at this I
think and say Flynn shouldn't have lied
it was absurd that he did lie he
absolutely it's pretty clear to me that
he did in fact lie and that is a problem
but also that this was some sort of
bizarre setup to have him hopefully lie
and appease a certain people that were
expecting him or wanting him to lie it's
just it's really a mess it is a mess
Vaughn clean it up for us no I wanted to
clean up Jesse's here because you go to
jail and I come to visit I will bring
the hair gel you could actually hide
things in his hair I think you could
hide like a file
seriously you really realize that you do
need a haircut it looks better than
Stephen Miller's here that's a low bar
okay all right so anyway I thought the
day started off with Donald Trump
wishing Mike Flynn good luck and I
thought hmm that's peculiar what's going
on here and then he says you know look I
think there's no evidence that struck
and paid well he said struck and page
may be deleted evidence and then of
course the reports that have come out
say that's not true something of what is
going on here what's going on here is
that all of a sudden this has become
highly politicized what's going on with
Mike Flynn in a court of law and you
have a judge who's well respected a
judge who by the way threw out a
conviction of Senator Ted Stevens a
Republican once he found that the
prosecutors he believed engaged in
misconduct so this is not a judge who's
any you know weak will oh oh no this is
strong competent judge well respected by
both sides but here is the thing when
you say to someone like Mike Flynn you
sold out your country Jesse I don't
think there's anything more damning than
that and this comes from a judge who as
you said got the 302 and you explain
though why did the judge say you sold
out your country what specifically was
he pointing to well look I think that
one of the things that is frustrating is
they should have kept the whole thing
under seal so not to give us a look at
this document that has three-quarters of
it redacted yeah
the judge has actually read the whole
thing you don't get to know so it leaves
that's all right that's why we have to
do it's poorly we don't know but let me
just add to what Dana just said which is
I I think and this is key also in
response to what Greg said about FAL n
and anybody else has gotten pardon mark
rich in the black gang Mike Flynn not
only was he advising a presidential
candidate while also representing a
foreign government he was getting
classified briefings from the US
government that's given to our top
presidential contenders and then once he
becomes the national security adviser
you can't get much higher than that this
guy also had been head of the National
Security Agency but he said he's now the
national security adviser Jesse and
what is he doing he's doing business for
a foreign government without register I
don't want to minimize it but everybody
in the swamp does that one trying to
track down some radical cleric and
sylvania hiding from the government you
want it you want it's not as shady as
you're making it out today I'm not
excusing it yes it was illegal by not
registering but let's not make it out to
be like Jessie this is a huge scandal it
is it's shocking you can't be the
president yes Tina she said near Dana's
been in the White House you can't be the
president's adviser Dana wouldn't lie
never even you know make a grammatical
error but you what this is about for the
media they can't find collusion right
they can't right now what is collusion
Russia maybe spent thousands of dollars
on ads to influence the election have
you seen those ads no seriously have you
seen them they're hilarious I can't even
talk about them because they're too
funny you know what you know we spent we
spend more money on our wardrobe than
Russia's spent on the ads yeah but they
spent a ton but they did things like
black lives matter they do things like
the Second Amendment advocates and they
just pushing people to break apart ads
were about addiction to self pleasure
yeah but they all tried to clean it up
for you helping Donald Trump know